nearly 2/3 of Americans do not get a
full eight hours of sleep did you hear
that
now one researcher is sounding the alarm
about what he calls a silent sleep loss
epidemic
he has scientists Matthew Walker he's
devoted more than 20 years to studying
sleep and his impact on health and
disease so he knows what he's talking
about
he teaches neuroscience and psychology
at the University of California Berkeley
he's published more than a hundred
scientific studies Walker's new book is
why we sleep unlocking the power of
sleep and dreams he says sleep
deprivation has a catastrophic impact on
our health work productivity and
children's education the book is
published by Scribner and imprint of
Simon and Schuster a division of CBS met
Walter good morning good morning the
greatest challenge that America faces in
the health arena
I think it's fast becoming one of the
greatest public health challenges that
we know eyes every disease that is
killing us in developed nations from
cancer Alzheimer's diabetes
cardiovascular disease stroke even
suicide they all have significant and
causal links to insufficient sleep and
if you look at the epidemiological data
it's quite clear to short sleep equals a
shorter life it was a dick sore cause
mortality
what's the link the link actually is is
many fold so upstairs in the brain we
know that it creates a toxic protein
build up a protein that's called beta
amyloid that toxic sticky protein is
related to Alzheimer's downstairs in the
body it demolishes your immune system if
you're not getting sufficient sleep and
it also activates stress chemistry that
leads to cardiovascular disease
increases in also cancer related
molecules you also want to eat more when
you're not getting sufficient sleep so
you're fatter so you gain weight more
quickly also even if you're exercising
we used to think of sleep as the third
pillar of good health that's not true
it's actually the foundation on which
those two other things sit diet and
exercise great about your book is its
research-based it's epidemiologically
based one-third of adults take naps what
does the research say about that
well naps are a double-edged sword
to be quite careful firstly ask yourself
why you napping sleep is not like the
bank it turns out you can't accumulate a
debt and then pay it off either by
napping or over sleeping at the weekend
it's an all-or-nothing event naps also
can be dangerous in the sense that
during the day the longer that we're
awake we build up sleepiness and that's
good it's healthy it means that we'll
fall asleep and stay asleep well at
night but if you nap during the
afternoon it's almost like a valve on a
pressure cooker you release some of that
sleepiness so then it makes it that much
more difficult to fall asleep in science
to your productivity and your good
feeling as well so naps if you can make
them regular can have productivity
benefits and you don't nap after 3 p.m.
if yeah if you're struggling with sleep
in the evening or if you can't nap
regularly the advice is don't nap at all
but naps do have some benefits to them
NASA figured this out back in the 1980s
they called it the NASA nap culture it
improved work productivity by about 34
percent overall alertness by about 50%
so if they're regular that's good you
write about sleeping pills the bad the
bad and the ugly
tell us why well firstly sleeping pills
do not produce naturalistic sleep I wish
they did but at this stage they don't
there are class of drugs that we call
the sedative hypnotics and sedation is
not sleep so you're simply removing
consciousness you're not producing that
realistic sleep the second aspect is
that they've been related to a higher
risk of mortality of death and a higher
risk of cancer too so just make sure we
get to this so what do you do to make
sure you get as much sleep as you should
so I think there are probably five key
tips firstly keep it regular go to bed
at the same time wake up at the same
time no matter what the second is
darkness we're actually a dark deprived
Society so at night try to dim your
lights only put half of the lights on
you don't need them all limit screen
time that will allow is that sort of
melatonin hormone to build up and get
you to sleep keep
cool degrees 65 to 67 it's strange I'm
turning it down yeah I've been doing
that yeah but your body needs to drop
its temperature to get to sleep and you
can help it to do that that's the third
thing temperature the fourth is actually
walk it out don't stay in bed if you've
been awake because then at that point
your brain learns the association
between your bedroom being about being
awake and many people will say to me you
know I'm sort of falling asleep on the
couch with television I get into my bed
and I'm wide awake and I don't know why
because you've learned the association
between bedroom being about wakefulness
get out go to a different room dark
light dim light read a book only return
when you're sleepy and then you'll
relearn the association between your bed
equaling sleepiness finally and it makes
me deeply unpopular um no caffeine after
2:00 p.m. and no nightcap alcohol is
probably one of the most misunderstood
chemicals it's also a sedative you're
just knocking yourself out it's not
naturalistic sleep and it also fragments
your sleep you wake up many more times
throughout the night and it also blocks
your dream sleep so you know imagine
food food the advice right now is don't
go to bed too full don't go to bed too
hungry thank you thank you Matt sleep
cures a lot of things why we sleep is on
sale now